der konflikt zwischen russland und der
ukraine droht zu eskalieren
nach dem gewaltsamen vorgehen der
russischen küstenwache gegen drei
schiffe der ukrainischen marine vor der
halbinsel krim beschließt der
ukrainische sicherheitsrat für 60 tage
das kriegsrecht zu verhängen das
parlament in kiew muss dem noch
zustimmen
die ukraine erricht vor gegen irgendwen
zu kämpfen
das kriegsrecht wird nur zur
verteidigung durch einen klinischen
territoriums eingeführt die ukraine
wirft russland vor drei ihrer marine
beschossen und festgesetzt zu haben
der vorfall ereignete sich an der straße
von kertsch eine meerenge zwischen der
krim und russland moskau blockiert
daraufhin die durchfahrt ins offene meer
grüne präses ist ein verstoß aufgetreten
und zwar mit ziemlich gefährlichen
methoden wird manöver in russischen
gewässern bringen natürlich bedrohungen
und risiken für die schifffahrt in
diesem gebiet mit sich der
un-sicherheitsrat in new york will sich
in einer dringlichkeitssitzung mit der
lage befassen derweil ruft
bundesaußenminister heiko maas alle
beteiligten auf die situation zu
deeskalieren die lage sei
besorgniserregend schreibt maß auf
twitter die beziehungen zwischen kiew
und moskau sind seit langem äußerst
angespannt